so with 12 000 haitian migrants getting
in will others be encouraged to follow i
want to go to jackson county texas
sheriff aj louderback joins me now i i
also want to mention that we did call
dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas we have
not heard back from him yet sheriff uh
it just seemed like such a
well-coordinated uh plan all of a sudden
30 haitian migrants emerged at the very
same time at the very same place at this
at this bridge under overpass for them
they were going back and forth to mexico
you know getting provisions and food and
things like that it's and now we're
hearing reports that more on the way
what are you hearing
i'm hearing the same charles and good
afternoon to you good good to see you
again
the um
you know it's it's obvious it's very
clear
that the the only thing the by the
administration here is for
uh in immigration reform is a wide open
border
with as many people as we possibly can
bring in the united states knowing full
well
that most will not report to an ice
to an ice station or to an ice agent uh
where they are in the united states and
they know this
this is all a very orchestrated very
strategic uh situation that we've seen
yes we've got another 15 20 000
um that are headed to uh headed to the
area headed to the texas border
and um
you know and our secretary of our
national security alejandro mayorkas who
really uh we we probably should hand
that title over to susan rice who's
actually calling uh most of the shots
here directly from the white house so
this is uh this is a situation that that
board patrol knows texas sheriffs know
this um
as we are completely inundated uh with
with lack of resources uh from the
policies of the bible administration
and i and i think your job is going to
get harder um you know on friday when
president biden spoke about the incident
uh with the uh the border patrol on on
horseback
you know it broke my heart to hear his
comments because i got to be quite frank
with you and i don't want to
editorialize too much but i want to get
this point out
you know he never misses an opportunity
to make black people feel bad that
republicans or others hate them he knew
that that that that patrolman wasn't
using that to strap those folks and yet
he made the border patrol agent and all
in the agency
bad guys so when they say they don't
want anyone coming to the border
i think the the whole message from the
campaign on has been hey we're the nice
guys we you can come wink wink will say
something in public but you are invited
get up here and we'll find a way to keep
you in i mean essentially that's the way
it comes across to me uh and again i
thought he had a great chance to be
presidential on friday to be honest
about something and not make it a
political point and not make people of a
certain race or nationality of color
feel like they're not wanted in this
country simply because of that so isn't
your job going to get much harder now
because i'm sure border patrol is going
to try to put lean back a little bit
they're not going to be aggressive at
all
well certainly we our our jobs are all
going to are going to grow our resources
are going to be further expanded on
exactly what this administration wants
to do we see no credibility with this
administration on what they say
the the anything that's effective
uh anything that the men and women of
border patrol
and our ice agents do here on our border
uh they're gonna be criticized for it's
not what they want what we saw with the
use of horses there was boar patrol
actually being effective on trying to
control the border
which is not what the administration
wants uh it's not what they plan for
it's not what they intend to do the
vision is clear
the federal government this federal
administration wants an open border and
is going to do everything they possibly
can
to complete that mission
yeah and the last line of defense is to
i guess shame those folks who are in
charge of keeping the borders safe for
everyone
sheriff lauterbach thank you very much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else